[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - AVERY*SUNSHINE,
"I GOT SUNSHINE"]
AVERY*SUNSHINE: Now family,
do you see the sunshine?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AVERY*SUNSHINE: Now I was gonna
do some talking, but I'm not.
Any sopranos?
AUDIENCE: [CHEERING]
AVERY*SUNSHINE: I
want you to sing.
Any altos?
AUDIENCE: [MURMURS]
AVERY*SUNSHINE: Any
tenors and basses?
AUDIENCE: [SCATTERED CHEERS]
AVERY*SUNSHINE:
What is you all do--
have you all been
drinking tonight?
Well sopranos, I want
you to sing something
that sounds a little like this.
[SINGING_"DO_DO"_HIGH]
Let me here you say it.
AUDIENCE: [SINGING]
AVERY*SUNSHINE: Get it.
AVERY*SUNSHINE: Aw, you better
sing it like you from Philly!
[LAUGHTER]
AVERY*SUNSHINE: Sing sopranos!
Now, altos, I know you
all-- there was only four
of y'all that sang,
but I know it was more.
So your part sounds
a little like this
[SINGING_"DO_DO"_LOWER]
Let me hear you say it.
AUDIENCE: [SINGING]
AVERY*SUNSHINE: I knew
it there was more 'tos.
Get it, girl.
She like this, too.
Get it!
You all made that
last part up though.
It's OK.
Now tenors and basses, you sing
something that sounds like,
[SINGING_"DO_DO"_LOW]
Let me hear you say it.
AUDIENCE: [SINGING]
AVERY*SUNSHINE: Aw, don't be
trying to put no stank on it
now!
Now listen, if you
remember your part, great.
If you don't, make something up.
Now I want you to
put them together.
Are you ready?
If you feel the sunshine
and you see the sunshine,
I need you to sing your part.
Are you ready?
AUDIENCE: Yeah!
AVERY*SUNSHINE: Here we go.
One, two, let me
hear you sing do!
AUDIENCE: [SINGING]
AVERY*SUNSHINE: There it is!
Come on and say
it again, say it!
AUDIENCE: [SINGING]
[MUSIC - AVERY*SUNSHINE,
"I GOT SUNSHINE"]
[APPLAUSE]